So, since we know that we are trying to write an equation and not just an
expression,I am going to start off by writing a equals in our box down here. So,
since I know that the left side of the equation is not going to change at all.
Then I can start to combine my like terms. Conveniently, our terms with w are
already written next to each other and our terms with n. It was so nice that we
did that for ourselves earlier. This is pretty straightforward then. Since these
are like terms, I can just add their coefficients. 36 plus 51 is 87. And I
multiply that by the variable w. 22 plus 50 is 72. And that gets multiplied by
the variable as well. Awesome.
We're one step closer to helping Grant figure out how much money he's going to
have after these first two batches of friends pay him.